لو كنت طبيبا تعمل في مستشفى وسط حرب
وجاؤوا اليك بجري حين في حاله حرجه اصيب
خلال القصف ولان الادويه قاربت على النفاذ
تماما ولم يبقى سوى مكان واحد في المستشفى
عليك ان تختار ايما تعالج هذا سيتلقى
العلاج والانعاش وذاك سيترك للموت هذا
بالضبط ما يعيشه العاملون في القطاع الصحي
بغزه يواجهون كل دقيقه هذا الاختيار الصعب
ويتخذون قرارات سريعه وسط صرخات الاطفال
الخاضعين لجراحات بتر دون تخدير ويعملون
بحسب ايميلي كالهان الممرضه الامريكيه
التي مكثت في غزه نحو ثلاثه اسابيع وسط
اجواء اقل ما توصف على حد تعبيرها
بالكارثي اذ يسمعون القصف وال الغارات
الجويه في اثناء الجراحات وفي بعض الاحيان
يهتز المستشفى من شده
الانفجارات مع انهيار مستشفيات غزه بسبب
القصف الاسرائيلي يواجه القطاع الصحي نقصا
حادا في الادويه والغذاء والمياه والوقود
ويعاني العاملون روفا صعبه جدا الامر الذي
يضعهم تحت ضغط نفسي كبير فيغدو كل يوم
خيارا بين من يعيش ومن يموت صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز الامريكيه نشرت تقريرا عن الاوضاع
الصحيه اشارت فيه الى ان قله من المصابين
بجروح خطيره يحصلون على سرير في المستشفى
وعدد اقل من ذلك يستخدم جهاز التنفس
الصناعي او التخدير في العمليات الجراحيه
ومنها جراحات الدماء
ا